porque seguimos analizando las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania
con nuestros invitados nos enfocamos en
cómo ha afectado el conflicto fuera de
la frontera saludamos entonces a esteban
actis él es doctor en relaciones
internacionales profesores e investigar
una facultad de ciencia política y
relaciones internacionales
eliminar de la universidad nacional de
rosario en argentina gracias a profesor
esteban por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 comencemos
entonces hablando de la división
geopolítica en el mundo debido a esta
guerra la nueva división entre rusia y
el bloque occidental una guerra fría 2.0
se puede llamarlo así
bueno es interesante las analogías pero
creo que el mundo está transitando un
momento geopolítico distinto en la
guerra fría de hoy la interdependencia
entre todos los actores del sistema
internacional hace que pensar en bloques
visto sea muy difícil pero si la
invasión de rusia a ucrania viene a
acelerar dos cuestiones que me parecen
importantes la primera es un mayor
acercamiento de rusia con china y
claramente la
distanciamiento en relativo de rusia con
occidente va a llevar a moscú a intentar
generar mayores vínculos
diplomáticos políticos comerciales y
financieros con chinas como un satélite
de la influencia china y por otro lado
lo que está demostrando la guerra es la
irrelevancia relativa podríamos decir si
de euros en el concierto internacional
está claro que europa como actor
internacional que venía sufriendo un
conjunto de
retracción es en su capacidad de influir
en la internacional bueno la
vulnerabilidad que está llevando este
conflicto a europa en materia energética
en materia de su capacidad de resistir
presiones extremas queda claro que es en
esa tendencia se acentúa en estos seis
meses
estaba le pregunto qué tanto jugó de
favor a esta guerra la política
expansionista de la otan no cercana a
las fronteras con rusia ese conflicto
realmente se podría haber prevenido
está claro que la expansión de la otan
por el este europeo ha sido uno de los
factores que moscú ha señalado como una
línea roja que justamente la otan ha
cruzado y la posibilidad latente de que
ucrania se sume a la otan si bien fue
desmentida los meses previos a la guerra
bueno ha sido el principal factor que ha
esgrimido
rusia en su accionar bélico entonces
desde esa postura está claro que
uno de los motivos que en moscú ha
esgrimido pero si uno mira el
comportamiento de rusia de putin y su
accionar bélico violando la sólida
territorial de ucrania y claramente es
una
expansiva en términos territoriales uno
puede también bueno plantear que hay
intereses ofensivos de rusia no
solamente desde una visión como decía
defensiva sino ofensiva en el sentido de
intentar recuperar bueno un prestigio y
un protagonismo internacional que
claramente con la disolución de la noche
objetico rusia había dejado entonces
hombres que bueno hay una combinación de
factores defensivos y ofensivos que no
se tienen que descartar para intentar
comprender el porqué de la decisión de
putin de invadir hace seis meses ucrania
hablemos ahora estaban de turquía a un
actor importante en este conflicto
porque a pesar de ser un miembro de la
otan también es cercano a rusia y al
gobierno del presidente vladimir putin
además fue gracias a turquía
aunque se pudo lograr este acuerdo para
poder exportar los granos ucranianos por
el mar negro represados o por esta
guerra que rol entonces juega turquía en
todo este conflicto de importancia de
este país y el presidente rumano
bien hoy en señaladas si no plantea
quienes son los actores están resultando
estado beneficiados interés no sin
trabajar en este conflicto claramente
turquía aparece como un gran actor
ganador no solamente por ese error el
diplomático de mediación que ha generado
justamente en este acuerdo tan
importante
para
para ayudar a revertir esta crisis
alimentaria global sino también porque
en términos económicos comerciales nos
miran los números desde turquía por
ejemplo es un país intermediario para
que rusia siga importando muchos
productos industriales y tecnológicos
que en teoría están siendo sancionados
por oxy entonces parece que en términos
políticos diplomáticos y en términos
económicos comerciales en rusia ha
aprovechado muy bien está tanto salero
que se encuentra en toda la zona
euroasiática y se ha reposicionado como
un actor geopolítico central no
solamente para pensar una solución de
este conflicto sino claramente para
pensar en las futuras implicancias de la
política internacional esta guerra
también ha sido característica por las
sanciones internacionales principalmente
por parte de eeuu y la unión europea
hacia rusia sin embargo vemos que pues
la economía rusa parece resistir
nuestras sanciones tienen digamos estos
castigo económicos el efecto deseado por
occidente lo van a tener en un largo
plazo
es interesante hay dos conceptos los que
los intervencionistas siempre usamos que
son es de sensibilidad y vulnerabilidad
un actor que experimenta costos por una
acción al externamente caso las
sanciones
y cambia las políticas y debe reducir
esos costos es un actor sensible de un
actor que experimenta costos por derecha
externo a pesar de cambiar sus políticas
los y experimentando es un actor
vulnerable está claro que rusia
adif la diferencia lo que pensaba
occidente es un actor sensible cambiando
sus políticas ha logrado que su moneda
vuelva a estar en los niveles pre guerra
tu sistema financiero no ha colapsado
esto no quiere decir que hemos uno
experimente costos en línea de su caso
está claro que la economía rusa no va a
salir indemne de estas sanciones pero
esa idea de que rusia va a colapsar no
han sido no se ha concretado y por lo
contrario europa que se planteaba como
sensible es muy vulnerable la crisis
energética atravesando
europa en general y alemania en
particular muestra que es justamente a
diferencia a lo que se pensaba en
febrero bueno la vulnerabilidad está es
parte de occidente y específicamente
europa y rusia ha sabido bueno con un
conjunto de políticas traer también
porque es un sistema político o no
democrático donde no hay el costo
político pero sí es verdad que todas
esas ideas de que rusia iba a
implosionar política y económicamente no
se ha llevado a la práctica ya
rápidamente para finalizar nuestra
conversación esteban le quiero preguntar
entonces si esas sanciones occidentales
sobre todo en europea no se convirtieron
digamos en un arma de doble filo en
cuestión energética ya que rusia ha
disminuido el suministro de gas por el
gasoducto nord stream
totalmente
como exportador de gas rusia al
disminuirlos el flujo de gas a europa
siente un costo económico no afecta su
economía en el funcionamiento pleno y
puede justamente estar intentando
lentamente buscar nuevos compradores de
todos sus bienes energéticos en el
cambio en el caso de europa en muchos
países que tiene una dependencia muy
fuerte de su matriz energética con el
gas ruso y eso hace que claramente la
'u' de la vida sea muy fuerte y lo señor
los precios que estamos observando
actualmente y los temores por el
invierno europeo hacen que justamente
bueno sea muy difícil en un corto plazo
en seis meses revertir más de 20 años de
interdependencia con la matriz
energética rus entonces en ese sentido
está claro que la evaluación previa de
una guerra que nunca se la pensó en un
lugar ahora que comiendo hace que hoy el
mayor dolor de cabeza no esté moscú si
vas en berlín y bruselas